This episode is sponsored by Fabulous,
the #1 self care app that helps
you start building better habits.
The first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25% off a Fabulous subscription.
Can you guess what this is?
I’ll give you a hint.
It’s extinct.
And it’s something that we probably would
never have expected to be filming for our channel.
Which I suppose you could say is sort of the
theme of today’s episode:
things we never thought we’d
be showing you, but here we are.
And we’re going to return to this and talk
about what it is.
But we’ve got a lot of unseen worlds to
get to first.
A while ago, James—our master of microscopes—received
a package from a coral farm containing a number
of exciting things for him to study under
the microscope, including a beautiful brick
that had been harboring all sorts of life.
We’ve done a few episodes on what he found,
but of course, there’s always more.
So James decided to keep the brick in a saltwater
tank so that he could see what else might
show up.
And one day, he found what seemed like an
array of tiny two-headed vases growing on
the surface of the brick.
These are tunicates, though they’re better
known by their very adorable name: sea squirts.
They get their name because they can squirt
water out of their bodies when something touches
them, or when they’re taken out of water.
Unfortunately, it turned out that collecting
and filming sea squirts was a bit of a challenge.
They’re big and fragile, which isn’t a
good combination when you’re trying to put
something under the microscope.
But the parts that James was able to observe
were still fascinating to watch.
This is the end of one of those tubes—which
are called siphons—coming off the sea squirt.
And inside are several algae living in symbiosis
with their sea squirt home.
The sea squirt has two siphons for a very
simple reason: one is to take things in, and
one is to take things out.
One siphon draws water into the sea squirt,
allowing it to pass through the organism so
that it can eat the little bits of plankton
and other food traveling on that internal wave.
And then, once the sea squirt is done with
the water, it passes it back out through the
other siphon.
Unlike the sea squirt, it was pretty easy
for us to record this ciliate under the microscope.
And there’s probably nothing shocking about
our channel showcasing a ciliate.
But we’ll get there.
This ciliate is called Lepidotrachelophyllum,
which is honestly a mouthful even by ciliate name standards.
And if you look around the organism, you can
see a fuzzy halo.
We can’t see what that halo is with our
microscope, but James’ mentor Professor
Genoveva Esteban has a scanning electron microscope
that is able to peer into that halo.
And with it, we can see thousands of tiny
organic scales layering the fuzz.
James usually finds these ciliates in a pond
next to his house.
So again, it’s not really a surprise to
see it show up here.
But this…this is more surprising.
This is a Lepidotrachelophyllum.
But unlike the previous ones we were watching,
which have just one mouth at the tip extending
and seeking food, this one has two mouths!
One in each of those finger-like projections
at the top of your screen.
James asked Professor Esteban about this ciliate
because she’s seen countless ciliates over
the course of her own microcosmos journey,
some of which she even drew for our microcosmos
poster that is available over at microcosmos.store.
She told James that yes, among her many strange
sightings, she’d actually once come across
a sample filled with hundreds and hundreds
of two-headed ciliates like this, though they
were a different species called Uronema.
So maybe one day we’ll find more of these
two-headed Lepidotrachelophyllum and this
will seem less shocking to us.
But for now, well, it is a strange sight.
And speaking of sight, this is an eye.
That’s not our smoothest transition, but
in our defense, it’s hard to switch gears
from a two-headed ciliate to this: a fish.
When James ventures out to waters, he brings
a net with him.
The goal is to gather ciliates, but you can’t
just stop other creatures from entering the
plankton net if that’s where they swim.
So that means sometimes our master of microscopes
becomes an accidental fisherman.
Ichthyology is not our strong suit, so we’re
not sure what kind of fish this is.
But if any of you know, feel free to tell
us in the comments.
Part of what we found fascinating is just
how iridescent its eyes are under the desk
lamp that James uses to light up more opaque
creatures like this one.
Unfortunately, the journey from water to microscope
isn’t great for fish.
It’s difficult to extricate them from the
nets.
And it’s also challenging to get the environmental
conditions of their new home just right.
After putting this fish back in its jar, James
returned the next day
and sadly found that it had died.
But he decided to keep watching the fish’s
eye because as grim as it is, we have to admit
that it's beautiful in its iridescence.
Eyes are complicated biological devices,
having to transmit light
that creates a usable image
for us to process.
That means filtering out light that is unfocused,
and that might interfere with the final image.
Humans and plenty of other animals rely on
melanin pigments in our eyes to absorb those
unfocused bits of light.
But fish eyes are iridescent because they
work differently from ours.
When researchers studied zebra fish eyes,
they found that the iris has a layer of guanine
crystals that reflect light back instead of
absorbing it.
That reflective action creates the iridescent
sheen while simultaneously bouncing the light
in a way that makes the fish less conspicuous
in its environment.
And that brings us back to the beginning,
to our weird extinct sample.
James has gotten plenty of strange things
delivered to his house in the name of microscopy.
But this is probably one of the strangest
so far.
This sample came from a bag of mammoth hair
that he got from Siberia.
How did James come by the opportunity to receive
a bag of mammoth hair?
According to him, he knows a guy who knows
a guy.
But apparently, it’s also not that hard
to find mammoth hair on the internet.
A quick search on eBay pulls up many listings
of mammoth hair, though we’re not quite
sure how believable their claims of authenticity
are.
The availability of this hair may be exciting,
but it’s also the result of a warming climate,
which is melting permafrost across Siberia
and revealing the ancient life that once called
the area home.
There’s something in all of this about the fact that shifts
in climate—which likely contributed to the
extinction of woolly mammoths—
are now revealing their remains.
But James wasn’t examining their hair to
resolve questions of extinction or explore
possibilities of resurrection.
He was hoping to find some ciliate buried
in this sample, perhaps wrapped up in a cyst
that might have protected it and kept it fused
to a strand of a woolly mammoth’s hair.
Unfortunately, he couldn’t find a ciliate,
but the search continues.
Because if he does find one, then James will
have found a ciliate that might have existed
when the woolly mammoth itself was wandering
the earth.
An ancient unseen world, unburied and revealed
in a tangle of hair.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you to Fabulous for sponsoring this
episode.
Fabulous is an app that was created by behavioral
science researchers to gently support your personal goals.
Habit changing and habit building is hard.
So, if you’re looking for ways to add a
new thing to your routine,
Fabulous is the way to go.
It makes it easy to set new goals and track
your progress as you reach your wellbeing goals.
You can choose a self guided style where you
track any of your habits or a guided approach
by selecting one of their dedicated programs
to support your wellness goals.
You’ll get personalized reminders, motivating
lessons to keep you going, and access to a
full library of exercises to support your
journey.
With over 30 million users, Fabulous can help
you whether you’re looking for ways to stay
focused at work or if you’re looking to
develop a whole new morning routine.
The app is 100% personalized to your goals
and with their daily coaching and goal setting,
you can start building your ideal daily routine
today!
The first 100 people who click on the link
in the description will get 25% off a Fabulous subscription.
We’d also like to thank all of the people
whose names are on the screen right now.
These are some of our Patreon patrons who
decided that they would like to give us some
money every month to help this channel exist.
So thank you again to all of them, and all
of you for watching and supporting this channel.
If you’d like to join our patreon community,
you can do so over at patreon.com/journeytomicro
If you’d like to see more from our Master
of Microscopes James Weiss, you can check
out Jam & Germs on Instagram
And if you’d like to see more from us, there’s
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.